[Music]
we'll quote you on that
you know that there we will go we'll
just put this clip we'll just put this
clip live
in mathematics you don't need to know
anything you don't need to do
anything by elena
this clip it's gonna be i think it's the
do bit you don't need to do anything
and then and the funny part is that it
fails sometimes so it just teases you
randomly
right well i guess we'll have to code it
up at the weekend hello folks and
welcome back to the channel um today
we're going to be talking with lena
voiter
but before then i wanted to spend about
10 minutes or so just talking about some
of the confusion i think that i've
noticed
arising from the kenneth stanley episode
so if this is interesting to you then
then please watch it otherwise you can
skip forward
on the table of contents to lenavoita
now i wanted to clear up a few things
right
the first thing is i i think if you take
one thing from that episode with kenneth
stanley
or his ideas that one thing
should be the concept of deception and
deception
is when your objectives or stepping
stones
they lead you in the wrong direction
right assuming that your goal which is
also a stepping stone is even
the right direction to be going in the
first place but it's a really important
concept
that any search problem has deception
which means we cannot trust the
gradients of the stepping stones
even reinforcement learning algorithms
they acknowledge this with reward
shaping
reward shaping is about creating
intermediate stepping stones
where you can trust the gradient so any
ambitious
objective has deception that's that's
really important
now any goal that requires knowledge
that we don't yet have and by the way
knowledge is the same as a stepping
stone
for example how do we build artificial
general intelligence or how do i become
a millionaire or a billionaire these are
deceptive goals
which means we cannot trust the
gradients
of the stepping stone right there's a
false compass
as discussed on the show some goals are
surprisingly
undeceptive like landing on the moon or
building rockets or building a bridge
or some software engineering projects
and this is because we already
understand
what all of the intermediate you know
stepping stones are
now in the case of landing on the moon
actually
some folks in china about 3000 years ago
discovered
uh the key stepping stones to make that
problem happen
so now we can monotonically increase on
the knowledge that we already have
and we know we can get to the moon it's
a different story of artificial general
intelligence
if we monotonically increase on gbt3
it's a false compass it will not
lead to artificial general intelligence
almost everything that happens in the
work environment
at the moment works on the principle
that we should exploit what is already
known
and not waste precious time with
deviations and people self-ideating and
innovating
i see this a lot right because i've
managed teams of data scientists and
machine learning folks
and all they want to do is build their
resumes and experiment with things and
be
researchers and so on and you know i can
completely understand
why a lot of the senior leadership in
large corporations do not want that to
happen
right it's horrifying because you think
my god people are wasting time and money
on things which are taking away my
predictability
so there's a huge kind of dichotomy
between science and engineering
science is about exploration and
engineering is about exploitation
and you can argue that in most
businesses the focus is on
is on exploitation so if you do any mba
course in business
the first thing they tell you is it's
all about predictability
it's about reducing surprise it's about
convergence
and it's about increasing velocity
that's what you learn on an mba course
right so um to be a good stakeholder
even that
i was on a presentation about this the
other day um the key
there that i was told is that to be a
good stakeholder you have to be
predictable
you have to be obedient you have to
treat other stakeholders like black
boxes you have to give them the
information that you want
you have to learn their behavior a bit
like you would a machine learning
algorithm and then you have to be able
to predict
what the output is so give them the
answer that you
want to give them and then you can
predict the output it's a similar thing
when you have direct reports
you want them to be as predictable as
possible you
it's no coincidence that in the
corporate world there is a certain
behavior that emerges of obedience and
consistency
and it's all about scale because to do
to do things fast in a large
scale organization with you know role
fragmentation multi-disciplinary teams
you need predictability and that's why
you have a certain type of people
in these uh kind of you know
institutions so
you know if you want to scale yourself
in a large corporate what do you do you
make yourself transparent and you'd be
as predictable as possible
right so there's a test what would tim
do if if people can answer what tim
would do it's a good test
that you can scale yourself if i know
what my reports do it's a good test that
i can delegate to them and i don't need
to be in the meeting anymore because i
can trust that they're going to do the
right thing
and okay so none of this should come as
a surprise
um but for good or bad it's the opposite
of stepping stone collection
right this is all about velocity it's
about exploitation it's the opposite of
innovation
innovation is about surprise a lot of
mba folks will tell you that they're
creating an innovative culture
they're not they're doing the complete
opposite they're creating an agile
high velocity culture there's a there's
a difference so when you read kenneth's
book and
keith said that he was making quite a
hyperbolic argument you know like a
a black and white argument but i don't
agree i think the most important thing
that that kenneth was pointing out in
his greatness cannot be planned book
is that there is a tyranny of objectives
now that
it's not hyperbolic if you understand
what he meant so in
in science and institutions in the
business world right now even in
education
there is no divergence and the reason
for that is the objectives are fixed so
we
get teachers to monotonically improve on
grades right so that is a convergent
behavior
divergence is all about discovering new
problems
right it's about problems it's not about
solutions so what should be clear
is that if you fix the objectives you
can't be discovering new problems
actually it blinds you to the discovery
of new problems that's the really key
concept
so yes it's certainly true that there is
some exploration out there
because there are some people in their
garages following their own gradient of
interest
without receiving any money from the
government or anything like that but
i think what kenneth is saying is that
as a society we are not discovering new
problems because we are so
focused on solutions what he's saying is
that
the government and large institutions
should pour huge amounts of money
into discovering new problems because
the the ironic thing or the paradox
is that it's only by looking for new
problems that we will discover better
solutions
to the problems that we already have
that that's it
right so the other misconception is that
people think
kenneth is arguing that we should
abandon objectives and not use
objectives
that's not true okay so in some of
kenneth's early work on quality
diversity
he was making that argument we should
still use objectives but use a different
type of objective
use an objective which has a kind of
behavioral characterization or entropy
which we can increase monotonically
which means we can trust it better as an
objective because it's less deceptive
so basically all of the early work in
quality diversity was about
creating objectives that had a better
gradient which had less deception
okay what he's saying now is that we
should
flip the script we should focus on
problems
not solutions we should focus on having
as many objectives as possible because a
system that has
a panoply of objectives has no objective
at all
that's the key thing just like evolution
we have a panoply or a cacophony of
niches
people following their own niches and
their own gradient of interest
that's what he thinks we should do now
and in the context of machine learning
he's advocating for meta learning he's
saying we should meta learn new
objectives
people have asked does pick breeder have
an objective
well again it's the same thing right
every single person in pick breeder is
allowed to follow his or her gradient of
interest
to its logical conclusion it's certainly
true that the gradients will be
co-linear in some sense because
they're all going to be earthly
gradients you know there is a divergence
to it because
people won't recognize the images but
when the images become
heliocentric or earthly then it'll
become a convergent behavior
so we'll talk about pick breeder in a
minute now deception is the single most
important concept if you take
nothing else away from the kenneth
stanley video please let it be deception
right once you clearly understand this
problem you will question
gradient-based methods for the rest of
your life i can assure you
this is it you just can't unknow this
information it's a little bit like when
waleed subber came on the show and was
saying about gbt3 you know it doesn't
understand
when you say a corner table wants a beer
it doesn't understand that the corner
table is a person
because there's this problem the missing
information problem
right in in data driven statistical
machine learning methods
the information is not in the data and
once you know this key concept you
recognize the problem everywhere it's
like a sore thumb it sticks out at you
and it's the same thing with deception
once you recognize this problem
you'll see it everywhere you'll see it
everywhere it's a huge problem
so yeah basically you will know where
the landmines are now once you
understand this concept of deception
so coming back to pick breeder why don't
we look at a phylogeny now this is one
of
the pictures that kenneth himself bred
and it looks like a pig or it looks like
some kind of animal
and if we trace all of its ancestry all
the way to the beginning
the key concept here is deception in a
search base so what kenneth is pointing
out
is that the intermediate stepping stones
look nothing like the end result
so this was truly a divergent process at
the beginning
this was just individual people
following their own path of
of you know gradient of interestingness
and it's only when
it got to this generation where suddenly
it became something that was quite
earthly or heliocentric
so this point of the phylogeny was
divergence
and this point is convergence and it's
really important that we make this
distinction
now let's use the example of rocketry
right so
the chinese a few thousand years ago
were experimenting with all sorts of
random things with fire and water and
goodness knows what else
i think there's something here called a
surface running torpedo
and it's only when they got at some
point in the lineage here
that it started to resemble conceptually
what a rocket is
so once you get to the key stepping
stone where you can now converge
or you can trust the gradient of
monotonic optimization
then it becomes an engineering problem
so this is what they did in the 1960s
they put a they put a man on the moon
so they had all the knowledge they knew
what the stepping stones were and they
could use a gradient-based optimization
and they could get a man on the moon
this is basically what we do in the work
environment at the moment we know what
the stepping stones are
and we are ruthlessly improving the
velocity of the process
because it's an engineering problem
right i personally believe that gpt3 is
here
so gbt3 is at a stage where we have a
stepping stone we have an objective
but it's a deceptive objective so if we
optimize on this gradient we're going to
go in the wrong direction
artificial general intelligence is down
here we're going to be going in the
wrong direction
now another key concept is is pick
breeder a good analogy for real life
because a lot of the argumentation here
hinges on that principle i strongly
believe it is right
and that is because we know for sure
that many ambitious
search problems even you know in
computer games for example they have
deception of course they have deception
so if deception exists and if
gradients have a false compass then why
are we using gradient-based methods
to find good solutions to these problems
it's completely balmy
now i wanted to give another example
here so this is the famous skull in pick
breeder
and as kenneth was saying right that the
early stepping stones do not resemble
the skull so if we trace it all the way
back to the beginning
as you can see it's just a kind of
pattern it's just a weird gradient
pattern
and the way neat works is that it hinges
on this principle that kenneth has
observed in evolution which is that
there's a monotonically increasing arrow
of complexity
and that's why the topology of the
underlying
cppn the convolutional pattern producing
network is increasing
in complexity so when we look at the
phylogeny here we have some stepping
stones that look nothing like a skull
and all of a sudden we have something
that looks very anthropomorphic
on the fourth stepping stone and at that
point it becomes a convergent process so
you can see in pickport
that loads of people now kind of branch
from this anthropomorphic
image and create lots and lots of
interesting children
so at this point it becomes a convergent
process but at this point it was a
divergent process
and the irony is if you try to find an
anthropomorphic image
directly you probably wouldn't find it
it's you're more likely to find it by
accident by following your own niche
or your own gradient of interestingness
that's the key thing with with
picbreeder now it's interesting to have
a quick look at this as well so as i was
saying on the previous episode a pattern
producing network
so it's it's just a neural network that
takes in a spatial input and gives you
an rgb output and you might be
interested to know well what was the
topology of that network for the skull
pattern
well this is it this is the skull
generating pattern producing network
and it's absolutely fascinating right i
mean the uh
i i think that the color tells you what
the weight of the connection was and
then these things here are
different activation functions and and
different neurons and as you can as you
can see this then produces the skull
pattern and this was learned
through a combination of the neat
algorithm being human augmented
by folks following their own gradient of
interest absolutely fascinating
so the other thing i wanted to do is
take you folks on a bit of a tour de
france of some of the approaches for
doing
a novelty search and and the lineage of
those approaches now in in the show we
were quoting this
this paper actually abandoning
objectives evolution through the search
for novelty alone
and this was one of the seminal early
bits of work in quality diversity and
novelty search so i think when
kenneth wrote his book greatness can't
be planned he was probably thinking
along these lines that was what he had
in his head now in the paper they have
an example of a hard maze which has
deception
and they give an example of what a
genetic algorithm using neat
with a the distance function as the goal
to the reward would look like but i'm
going to fill in the gaps here so
what i've done is i've imagined what
would it look like if you had
hard maze which was a reinforcement
learning algorithm with epsilon greedy
now the whole point here is that search
problems have deception so if you
if you have the wrong objective which
has deception which is to say you can't
trust the gradient of optimization
it means that you're going to get stuck
in some kind of local minima
so i'm imagining that if you had a
reinforcement learning agent and you
trained it on lots of different episodes
probably the coverage along the map
would not would not look very good
it would look something like this okay
so the objective here is fixed and this
is why we have reward shaping and
reinforcement learning because we can't
trust the gradient of the objective
we have to create stepping stones
manually where we can optimize on on the
sub-gradients of those stepping stones
now the next thing he did was he this is
what he showed in the paper so he said
well what if we have a genetic algorithm
using neat with the distance to the goal
as a reward now a genetic algorithm
it's all about the diversity it's a
population based method
so being able to cross over diverse
instances
it actually gives you better coverage
around the map right so still one
goal which is the distance to the
objective but
we are introducing this concept of
diversity preservation and crossover
the next thing that kenneth showed and
this is the key idea with novelty search
is what if we do not optimize at all on
the distance to the goal
right and personally i would argue that
it's cheating because in many
in many situations it's a partially
observable problem and you don't
actually know what the distance the goal
is so you know there's an argument to do
this anyway but
what we do here is that it's still a
genetic algorithm it still has one
objective
but we design the objective in a very
clever way we use a behavioral
characterization
right so the objective now is map
coverage
right and the really clever thing about
using this
this behavioral characterization which
has which is kind of like entropy or map
coverage
is it means that you can monotonically
increase it so if you monotonically
increase it
you trust the gradient and it means that
a gradient based method will actually
give you
better map coverage so so that this is
not abandoning objectives this is
basically
designing better objectives but the the
irony here
is that it's a better designed objective
so you could still use a gradient based
method all he's doing is he's designing
an objective that has
a gradient which is trustworthy the
other thing i wanted to talk about with
genetic algorithms in general is that
they are convergent
right so you might think by having
diversity preservation by having a kind
of
entropic behavioral characterization
that you would overcome
this convergent behavior but you don't
you don't right
it's still convergent and the reason
it's convergent eventually
is you have a fixed objective right so
if even this genetic algorithm with neat
using the behavioral entropy as a
fitness function if you look at the
convergent behavior it will still
converge it's still
an asymptote this is why we need to move
towards meta learning the problems
looking at the problems as well as the
solutions because if the problem is
fixed
a problem is the same thing as a
stepping stone right so if you're if
you're imputing the knowledge of what
the stepping stone is
into the algorithm then by definition
it's going to be subject to deception
you need to be learning new problems
so the other thing is before we get to
poet stanley has been doing some other
work so
you may have heard of this go explore
which is um kind of like an
evolution of the behavioral
characterization problem
so i would say this is still an
incremental step
of quality diversity and it's overcoming
two of the major problems that they
saw with quality diversity algorithms
which is namely detachment and
derailment
so in this detachment example they show
what that looks like so you might have
an intrinsic reward that's distributed
throughout the environment
and then an algorithm might start by
exploring the purple
a nearby area with an intrinsic reward
and then by chance it might explore
another equally profitable area
and then exploration fails to rediscover
the promising area that it's detached
from
so you get detached in this region
because it had no novelty so the idea
there is to
you know almost start from a region that
was discovered before just to get around
the detachment problem
the other problem they talk about is
derailment which is where there's no
mixability between
nodes in in the phylogenetic tree which
means that the agent was derailed from
returning to the state that that is once
in so
i see this is very very incremental
really so
in my opinion all of this is still old
hat this is not interesting
the really interesting thing that's
happened is with poet
now poet was released by uber stanley
was working for uber a few years ago
and this is where things really got
interesting so
in poet you have a meta objective and
you learn objectives through
meta-learning
so in poet you have these agents and you
have environments and the environments
kind of monotonically increase and you
swap the agents over
so all of the um the environments are
basically the same thing as problems
right so the idea is that you're
focusing on problems not just solutions
and you're meta learning a curriculum so
there's a really good image here showing
a curriculum that was learned as part of
poet and
i showed in the video last week an
example that jeff cloone talked about
where
there was a really complex environment
and in order to
overcome the deception of that
environment we needed to kind of cross
over
with one of the simpler environments and
then come back again so
the idea here is that we are learning a
curriculum but the curriculum is so
weird
that we wouldn't have been able to come
up with it ourselves remember in order
to do
things like artificial general
intelligence or to solve complex
problems
we do not know what the stepping stones
are we have to learn the stepping stones
or we have to discover the stepping
stones
and this is precisely what poet is doing
it's a stepping stone collector
right now the other fascinating thing
that i thought about is why don't they
use something like poet for language
modelling
so you could have a meta objective which
is your perplexity
and then you could have some kind of
increasing curriculum
of tasks which could be meta-learned and
that may well overcome the deception in
the world of language modelling
right why don't they do that maybe they
will do that i don't know and i also
said in the show that this is very
similar to france while shelley's
conception with the art challenge
well the whole idea of francois chole's
newer program search conception is that
first of all it's a search problem
and secondly you are meta-learning to
solve problems
that you don't know about right i think
he called it developer aware
generalization
so actually francois choulet and kenneth
stanley they're they're going in the
same direction
we need to be thinking about learning
problems that we are not yet aware of
in order to solve problems that we are
aware of now
okay fantastic anyway i really hope that
that clears up some of the confusion or
maybe it's just created more confusion i
don't know but
let's move on to lena voiter thank you
very much hi there
welcome to this conversation with lena
voita
as you know we at machine learning
street talk
are always extremely excited to talk to
new guests and
guests from different fields and
sometimes we get a bit too excited
so this time we actually forgot to press
record
for the first 10 15 minutes for this
conversation i'm so sorry about this
yeah it's well it's it's our bad as well
now fortunately we
caught it in time we need to build
like this could be a fun machine
learning project you know that
so tim in your chair will build like a
taser do you know michael reeves from
youtube
should watch michael reeves he's like an
engineer
so he does a lot of stuff with tasers so
we'll build
a taser into your chair and then
whenever
whenever like we have a machine learning
model that detects
when like the conversation starts when
you do like the intro like oh we have a
guest here
and when the record is not active on zen
caster it just tases you
so i'm now the sort of pre-scriptum
clown
that is supposed to tell what went on
during these first 10 minutes
we were just introducing the basic
notions
of how language models can fail
specifically
machine translation models and in
general sec to sec models
so in a sec to sec model and let's
take the example of machine translation
you do usually have
some kind of an input sentence in one
language
and then you have some kind of an output
sentence in another language now
initially you have none of the output
sentence but you are
building the output sentence usually
token by
token you can do this in an auto
regressive manner in that
you predict the first token and then you
feed
the input sentence plus the first token
again into the system to predict the
second token and then you take that
in predict the third token and so on
this has been giving very good results
however there is a problem with it
what you do when you train these systems
is that you have
the source and the target sentence
readily available
so you can always feed in not the token
you yourself predicted but you can
actually feed in
the true token of the target sentence
and that is called teacher forcing
now teacher forcing is very attractive
not only because
you train your model with actual good
data but also because
the samples if you do it like this are
independent meaning you can
parallelize it you don't have to do
weird loops during your training and so
on
however at training time you do have the
target sentence
and you feed in the correct token every
step
at test time you feed in the token that
you yourself predicted so there's a
mismatch there
between the training inputs and the
testing inputs
so just to give an example if you
translate the german sentence
uh dikatse ist like is like eats
it it means the cat eats um
if you go about and predict the first
token you
input the german sentence plus nothing
and the system might predict the and
then you
input the german sentence plus the word
the
and the system predicts the second token
now the correct token would be
cat but let's say your system is
confused and
outputs dog so during training you know
that there should be cat so you
your best option is to feed in the word
cat again
during testing you don't have this you
output
dog so you feed in dog again and you can
quickly see that if your model makes
some mistakes then it sort of builds up
on these mistakes and the input of the
model gets further and further away
from what it has seen during training
but we discussed different failure modes
of
these models if you think about what a
model like this has to do it has to do
two very different things first of all
it has to translate the source sentence
so that means that the tokens that it
outputs
must somehow be the tokens in the source
sentence but just in the different
language so if there is
a token cut in german there
should be a cat somewhere in the english
sentence
however the second objective is to make
the output sentence as grammatically
correct as possible in the target
language
so a very easy approach would simply be
to translate each token from language a
to language b
but that would be a horrible translation
not because the information isn't there
but because it's grammatically incorrect
so there are these two conflicting
objectives
and it can be that during testing one
can just sort of overpower the other and
that leads to failure modes
if the translation information objective
wins out
you're going to see really horrible
translations
but that contain sort of all the
information of the source sentence
these models even they tend to repeat
themselves
simply because so they they go like cat
cat cat cat cat
just because that's very probable given
the source sentence and it doesn't
really look at
what it's produced so far in the output
so it doesn't care about grammar
the other failure mode is the opposite
when it doesn't know anymore how to
translate the source sentence so it
says like well i'm screwed here i might
as well just
you know give you a grammatically
correct sentence in the target language
a hallucination
a hallucination a hallucination at least
i'll get
some low loss that way and so it will
continue
it will sort of start the output
sentence and it will continue completely
disconnected from what it should
translate
as long as the sentence is grammatical
because that is still
a low loss output so if you can't
satisfy the two objectives
it will prefer one over the other and
that will sort of
uh give rise to these different failure
modes of the model
so that was what we introduced in these
first
few minutes and we are of course very
sorry
that we lost that footage and we are
extra
extra careful and checklisty in the
future
which probably means that it will for
sure happen again because i just
jinxed it alright i hope you have fun
see ya
yeah so i did run a little competition
on our discord server i was curious if
any one of our
esteemed members could understand what
the hell yannick was talking about just
based on these screenshots
and we had some interesting contenders
actually so
sky core says no kitten stepping on the
white house
i thought that was um quite intriguing
actually um
an adroit suggestion ex-master 96 says
i'm so confused right now well it is
quite confusing i'll grant
henry the meme guy says has he finally
overdosed on amphetamines
caffeine and lost his mind well we all
know that's why he wears the glasses now
don't we
um al beebag says please
don't let the kadza die he didn't
honestly um
yannick's really good about stuff like
that anyway um
i suppose the show must go on hello lena
elena your blog is incredible lots of
visualizations and animations
and i think it really makes it
digestible for people to understand so
yeah it's great that you've done that
thank you do you know um valia fedorova
yes yes i met her at icml
probably about yeah nearly two years ago
now but
yeah it's it's cool that you that you
know her
she's really nice yeah okay so this is a
quick detour this is lena's blog
lena hyphen voiter.get it's absolutely
incredible so on here she has all of her
publications of course
but she also has this blog and this blog
is absolutely beautiful she uses
visualizations and graphics in a way
that you don't often see actually it
reminds me a bit of
uh robert lanz who we had on the podcast
so let's have a look at some of these
articles so um the most recent one is
source and target contributions to
neural machine translation predictions
okay so we'll go through
of course she's written a paper on this
as well but um her blog makes it so much
more easy to understand
so in this she's talking about what
yannick was saying before right so
models
hallucinate as you can see there's a
kind of continuum of influence between
the source so what goes in and the
target what came out because as you
rely on predicted tokens in in the
prefix then
the model has a tendency to hallucinate
so she talks about this dichotomy
between
the the source and the prefix and she
says that models suffering from exposure
bias are more prone to over-relying on
the target history and hallucinating so
that's
you know exposure bias is something that
increases as you have
more and more prefix tokens that were
previously predicted and you're not
using teacher forcing as yannick was
talking about before
okay so models trained with more data
rely on the source more
um confidently and the training process
is non-monotonic
actually has some distinct stages which
is quite interesting so
she says well what influence is the
source or the target
she said that we may expect that some
tokens are predicted based on mostly
source information so informative tokens
while others are based on mainly
target history so determiners but how do
we know which information
was used and her tldr here is that
models often fail to properly use these
two
kinds of information and this is
illuminated in some papers on this
matter so if you look at the
the attention weights on some of these
transformers models some of these models
are only paying attention to punctuation
or the eos token
which means clearly they're not actually
paying attention to anything in in the
input so they must be hallucinating
which is interesting
now how do you reason about the
contribution from the source
so there's this thing called layer wise
relevance propagation now i didn't
realize this but it's very similar
to one of the original attribution
methods in computer vision do you
remember grad cam
where you have an image going in and you
want to kind of figure out well which
input pixels were most responsible for
creating a given prediction
and it turns out that you can do this in
pretty much any model and that's what
lennar is advocating that we do in these
transformers models so then of course we
can figure out which
input tokens were most responsible for a
particular prefix
so she points out that it's unclear how
to use
a layer-wise method to something which
isn't completely layered because an
encoder decoder architecture is is of
course different to these traditional
cnn type models but she asserts that the
total relevance is still propagated
through the decoder and
the relevance leaked to the encoder is
propagated through the encoder layers
and she kind of demonstrates that with
this animation here
in her paper she talks about how to
extend this lrp method to the
transformer
but anyway let's do some experiments so
she looked at the total contribution and
entropy of contributions right so the
total contribution
is the contribution of the source which
is one minus the contribution of the
prefix
and she also looked at the entropy of
the contributions which tells us how
focused the contributions are whether
the model is confident in the choice of
the relevant tokens
whether it spreads its relevance across
the entire input
now the other thing she points out is
she's interested in general patterns she
doesn't want to focus on kind of micro
patterns so she averages over the entire
data set
now this is really interesting so when
she does this she notices that there's a
general pattern
so as the target or the prefix token
number increases
the model increasingly hallucinates
because it's paying less and less
attention to the source
and this this graph here demonstrates
that quite nicely
and also when you look at the entropy of
the contributions there's a really
interesting curve shape so at about 10
to 15 tokens
the entropy is is increased which means
it has
increasingly less idea about where to
point to in in the source but
it's kind of fascinating that there'd be
this curvy shape and then the entropy
would go down again at 20 and then go up
again at the 23rd token
now another way to reason about this is
rather than using the reference
prefixes so the reference translations
why not use the beam search
translations because they're more
regular and they're kind of surprising
the model less because you know you're
you're putting the model in a
comfortable place so to speak
so she asserts that beam search
translations are usually simpler than
references
and indeed when when she compares them
using the beam search prefixes
the um model is more confident about the
source so it's hallucinating less
as time goes on it's the same thing on
the entropy so on on the
on the beam search the entropy is lower
which means it's more confident about
the
the source so she hypothesizes that the
simpler prefixes are more convenient for
the model
yeah so one way of visualizing this is a
bit like tributaries
or little rivers right so if you give a
model something that's inside a
tributary so inside
something that it knows about then it'll
just immediately
run with it and in this case a tributary
means it actually understands some
relationship between your source and
prefix
if you give a model something let's say
outside of the manifold or outside of
the tributary
then the model no longer understands
what to do so it'll just start
hallucinating and it will just
predict something that's grammatically
correct because
it can't really make any relationship
between what you've given it
and the source another thing she tries
doing is just putting completely random
prefixes in there and as you might
imagine
the model starts hallucinating quicker
because it's just got no idea what
you're talking about it doesn't fit any
frame of reference that the model has
so anyway um i really recommend you
check out this article it's beautiful
finally she asserts that the training
process is non-monotonic with several
distinct stages so when she plots this
over time
especially looking at the relation you
know of the source contributions to the
prefix attention
it immediately goes down and then it
goes
up again and then it seems to converge
after about 20 or 30
000 training batches which is really
interesting and you know
perhaps you wouldn't have expected that
to happen so the second article on
lena's website is this information
theoretic probing with
mdl what's mdl it's the minimum
description length
everyone these days is talking about the
minimum description length whether it's
francoise charlay in his measure of
intelligence paper or
actually it's quite funny every time you
meet an academic with a with a russian
accent they will use the word
golem a goal of complexity like every
fifth word it's like oh my god of
complexity
um i had a phd supervisor who was like
oh yes i was just going outside
for a walk down the road earlier and i
was looking at the sky and considering
the kuruma ghoul of complexity anyway so
it comes up everywhere
it's it's basically the minimum
description length for anything so it
comes up a lot in in compression as well
and information theory but anyway lena
says that pro being classified probing
what does probing mean
probing means measuring you know so like
an accuracy would be a probe
probing classifiers often fails to
adequately reflect differences and
representations and how they can show
different results depending on the hyper
parameters so a lot of this is about
accuracy isn't a very stable method
right so she proposes an information
theoretic probing
which measures this minimum description
length of the labels given the
representations
and the really cool thing here is that
rather than just showing the final
quality of the probe so the accuracy for
example
and this mdl also shows how hard it was
to achieve
um you know that that particular
representation and it's more stable
so how do we understand if a model
captures a specific linguistic property
so in
what we do now is we have data we have
representations
and we have labels and we are measuring
to to what extent do the representations
capture
the labels now standard probing is we
just use the accuracy
but we know that the accuracy of a
classifier is used to measure how well
these representations encode the
property
looks reasonable and simple right wrong
okay so she says that while simple
probes are very
popular several sanity checks have
showed that differences and accuracies
fail to reflect the differences in the
representations right
so houston we've got a problem the
accuracy of a probe is not always
reflecting what we want it to reflect so
she introduces this information
theoretic viewpoint
okay so what we're getting to here the
tldr of this article is that regularity
and representations with respect to
labels can be exploited to compress
the data right so machine learning and
compression they are basically the same
thing
when we were talking to sarah hooker she
was telling us about this that you know
the reason why the lottery ticket
hypothesis works you can prune 90
of the connections in a neural network
and it still works sometimes it works
even better than it did with all of the
ones in there so
um what's happening with all of those
neurons right so they are learning all
of the challenging or low frequency
attributes you know all of the examples
that are sitting
uh very close to the decision boundary
or you know ambiguous between two
classes
you know we're wasting most of the
representational capacity right
so clearly if we had a lot of regularity
in our data
then we would need fewer parameters to
encode it so
she has quite an interesting kind of way
to represent this so
we've got alice and bob and let's
imagine that alice has
all of the the data and the labels from
the data set
and bob only has the representations and
alice wants to communicate
the labels to bob so transmitting the
data is a lot of work right so
surely alice has got a better way to do
this which is compressing the data
so the formal task here is to encode the
labels knowing the representations in an
optimal way
so essentially what we're getting into
here is the cross entropy
between the labels and the
representations that is
the the data code length right and so
learning is compression
and the amount of effort is related to
the strength of regularity in the data
so if there is strong regularity then
the data can be
expressed with very few examples and
vice versa
so what we're getting into here is
variational methods
and by the way when we interviewed carl
fristan the other week we were
well you know when i was doing my
background research i was learning all
about variational methods and
inferences optimization and of course
the kl divergence and so on and all of
this stuff's really interesting we
didn't properly get into it
on the episode so if you folks are
interested in us doing an episode on
that then
more than happy i i know keith would
love to do a show on that
but this is quite interesting actually
so
linda's got a section in the article
that says i hereby confirm that i'm not
afraid of scary formulas wonderful so
you have to explicitly say that you want
to see it but
all of this should be familiar to you if
you've studied variational methods and
the kl divergence
so the tldr is that the uh the mdl
methods are stable and the accuracy is
not so the mdr is is a much better
uh you know measure of probing for
machine learning
models because it characterizes not only
the probe quality but how difficult it
was
to achieve it the representation right
now finally um the other article that we
talk about today is this evolution of
representations in the transformer
she says we look at the evolution of
representations of individual tokens and
transformers trained with different
training
objectives so translation language
modeling like gbt3
master language modelling like bert so
denoising water encoder
and she looks at it from the information
bottleneck perspective right so
she shows that language models gradually
forget the past when forming predictions
about the future
bert style models the evolution proceeds
in two stages of context encoding and
token reconstruction
and machine translation representations
get refined with context but less
processing is happening
she says instead of measuring the
quality of the representations obtained
from
a model on some auxiliary task we
characterize how the learning objective
determines the information flow in the
model
so she looks at how the representations
of the individual tokens in a
transformer evolve between the layers
under different learning objectives
and uh essentially she uses the
information bottleneck perspective to do
this but that's just a clever way of
saying she's looking at the mutual
information
so what are the um the three main tasks
in these nlp models so the first one is
machine translation so
given a source and a target sentence
predict words in the target sentence
word by word
um the language modeling and you'll know
this from gbt3 of course so that just
estimates the probability of a word
given the previous word in a sentence
and
master language modelling which is the
birthstar model that's essentially
trying to
fill in the gaps so you mask out a word
in the input sentence and then it will
tell you
what that word was right so we're
interested in
how the representations evolve between
the layers in these transformers
architectures
but how does it change depending on the
um the task
right so all three of the models start
out with the same representations of the
of the tokens or the sub words that go
in and they also have the
identity and position but the way that
the information flows across the layers
is different depending on the objective
and that's the main interest here
so um her hypothesis is that these these
token representations undergo changes
layer from layer
and the interactions and relationships
between the tokens
change and the type of information which
gets lost and acquired
also changes as you progress through
these transformers models
so the tldr here on this information
bottleneck is that
the evolution is in squeezing a relevant
information
about the input while preserving
relevant information now if we click on
this information bottleneck paper i mean
what have we got here so that is we
squeeze the information that x provides
about y through a bottleneck formed by a
limited set of code words
x uh this constrained optimization
problem can be seen as a generalization
of rate distortion theory
that's getting a bit heavy going
isn't it right let's come back to where
we were
now the problem is we only have the
representations of the individual tokens
not the entire input
but we can view every model as learning
a function from input x to output y
now the first approach that she uses
here is is computing the mutual
information
uh with the input so the mutual
representation of the representation for
the
for the successive layers with the with
the input with what went in
and what she shows here is absolutely
fascinating right so
depending on the training task for
example bert star models these denoising
auto encoders the master language model
they actually
maintain a fairly high mutual
information with the input even as you
go through the successive layers but
machine translation and language
modelling they progressively forget
about the input
so if they're forgetting about the input
then what is happening right so
what she what she does then is she looks
at the mutual information with both what
goes in and what goes out
and as you can see there's a commensura
increase in the mutual information with
the output
as we go through the successive layers
but the the pattern
of that commensurate increase changes
depending on the training objective
um so with master language modelling it
looks like a kind of sigmoidal pattern
whereas with language modelling it looks
like a kind of quadratic curve so it's
very interesting
so she talks about some tricks she uses
to estimate the mutual information in
this setting because it's quite
challenging she had to use an
approximation
but if we get to the rub here right the
rub is that
mass language modeling preserves the
token identity more than anything else
so when you look at just the token
identity through the different layers of
the transformer
on mars language model it's modeling
it's significantly preserved
she's got a great illustration of this
concept actually so uh she gathered
representations of tokens is our were
was from lots of different sentences and
visualized their disney projections
so the act the x-axis here are different
layers
in the model and what's fascinating here
is that the master language model so the
bert type model actually preserved the
individual tokens throughout the
successive layers in the transformers
model significantly more than the
language model and the machine
translation
the other thing is that um machine
translation best preserves the token
position
so she took a large number of
representations of the same token for
different tokens
for each occurrence let's look at the
position or the top k neighbors and
evaluate the average position distance
and again when we look at a disney
visualization here you can see that
machine translation significantly
preserves
the position of the token compared to
language modeling and
master language modelling okay so she
concludes by saying that with the
language modeling objective
as you go from the bottom to the top
layers the information about the past
gets lost
and predictions about the future get
formed for bird type models the
representations initially acquire
information about the context around the
token
partially forgetting the token identity
and producing a more generalized token
representation
the token identity then gets recreated
in the top layer
for machine translation though
representations get refined of context
and less processing is happening
and most information about the word type
does not get lost
this is absolutely fascinating this
reminds me a little bit of our
conversation with simon corblet a few
weeks ago because he had a paper which
was all about
the evolution of representations through
you know let's say a convolutional
neural network
with different loss functions so it's
still the same task essentially but it's
different loss functions and he
demonstrated that
actually the representations are pretty
much the same apart from the penultimate
layers or you know the last sort of
20 of the layers there was a divergence
but of course here there's significantly
more divergence because the training
tasks are
significantly more divergent i would say
so yeah
any kind of um approach like this to
reason about
the evolution of representations and the
behaviour of neural networks i think
it's absolutely fascinating and i'm
going to really look forward to
discussing this with lena today okay now
the most
important thing that lena has got on her
website other than her papers and blogs
and so on is the nlp course it says nlp
course for you in the top right hand
corner you folks must check this out
sebastian ruder actually
featured this recently on his newsletter
and sebastian ruder pretty much is the
god of of the nlp world in case you
folks didn't know
so in this course again in
characteristic style for lena she has
formulated everything beautifully and
she's
used a lot of graphics and a lot of
really cool layout techniques
so she has the concept of lecture blogs
seminars and homeworks
research thinking related papers and and
lots else besides so
on the left hand side you can see the
structure so she's got an entire course
on
word embeddings and i mean it's too much
for me even to go through but this is
absolutely crazy so one hot vectors
distributional semantics count based
methods word to vec
glove research thinking related papers
yeah it's absolutely incredible she's
also got
a course on text classification
so in here she's got a general view
feature
uh features and classifier generative
versus discriminative classic methods
naive bayes
svm neural networks recurrent
networks convolutional networks
multi-label classification
practical tips embeddings data
augmentation
analysis and interpretability research
thinking again
she's also got an entire section on
language modelling
which is what gpt3 does so she starts
off with a general framework talking
about text probability
um engram language models neural
language models
um generation strategies so things like
top k sampling and
coherence and diversity and sampling
with temperature all the stuff we talked
about on the gbt3 video
evaluation practical tips analysis and
interpretability and research thinking
again
and she also has a course on seek to
seek an attention and transfer learning
as i said i mean this is just too much
for me to go through now um
honestly if you want to have a really
good introductory course to
everything in natural language
processing this is the best that i've
seen
this really is the best that i've seen
so please go to len's website it's
lenna hyphenvoiter.github.io
forward slash nlp underscore course and
of course we'll put the link in the
description but
this really is incredible so please do
go and check that out
i will need another cup of tea so i i
operate roughly 2.5 percent better on
pepperminty
yeah peppermint tea exactly
welcome back to the machine learning
street talk youtube channel
and podcast i'm here today with my two
compadres
sayak the neural network pruner pool and
yannick
lightspeed culture now today we have an
incredible
guest we've got lena voiter a phd
student at the university of edinburgh
and the university of amsterdam
previously she was a research scientist
at yandex research
and she worked closely with the yandex
translation team
she still teaches nlp at the yandex
school of data analysis now um
lenna has created an exciting new nlp
course on her website which is called
lena hyphenvoiter.github.io
we'll link it in the description she has
one of the most well presented blogs
i've ever seen
where she discusses her research in an
easily digestible manner
she uses lots of visualizations and
animations which i think
really communicate her ideas in an
innovative way so picking up the
conversation where we left off
what is hallucination and exposure bias
hallucination and exposure bias are
paying too much attention to the prefix
hallucination is when you just ignore
the source
because you want to produce something
that's grammatically correct
based on what you've already produced so
it's not necessarily that you made a
mistake in translation it's just that
you you just stop start ignoring
the input the source and you're just
continuing what you do because
that's at the beginning of a translation
you have no information
right all you have is the source
and then you you might want to pay a bit
of attention but as you translate
you get more and more already translated
tokens
and then the language model part kicks
in and then the model can be like
oh i know how this sentence is going to
finish i know i know i don't even need
to consider the other language anymore i
already know i can fit like this is
the people that say i already know what
you're going to ask then they answer
a question that but you you're going to
ask something different
so this is this hallucination is a bit
like this
as exposure bias is more that the
distribution differs between
training and inference so in training
you always replace
you always input whatever token the gold
standard has so you input the source and
then you input the target
up to token k and then you try to
predict token k plus one
but all the k tokens are like perfect
they're from
a real good translation but now at
inference
you want you put in your own tokens
and that looks a lot different so when
you make a mistake
you're all of a sudden in a situation
where you've never been before
and then you're not trained for this so
anything can
can go wrong so leno maybe there seems
to be a straightforward
fix in that during training can we just
also input the tokens of the
of the language model is that or maybe
even incorporate data augmentation so to
speak yeah there are
variety of different ways to fix
exposure by the
fix to some extent but yeah
it helps to some extent but
hallucinations still happen
and basically basically and in
one part of the paper we are going to
discuss here we do look at it as this
connection between exposure bias and
hallucinations
so basically what a model is doing if
it's strain was different between
objectives and
uh if there's a connection between
exposure bias and how frequently a model
is hallucinating so lena you seem to be
doing a lot of
investigations into how these models
work
did you i see on your on your blog and
your papers there seem to be a lot of
like
you look into probes and you look into
how sources and targets influence
the final predictions and so on do you
is that a general interest of yours or
how did you go in this direction because
a lot of people who go into nlp or so on
you know they want to train the models
that do something they want to train the
models that
produce the language and beat the the
wmt
benchmarks and so on your work seems to
focus a lot on
explaining the models which i absolutely
love i i think
there is not enough research in this
direction if i have to explain this
maybe it's because um from the very
beginning of my phd i was already
working
with the anti-translate team and
almost instantly i understood that
almost all this
stuff which is going on in research
claiming that
they have some improvements actually
they don't if we're talking about
really high resource settings and people
who are really
trying to optimize things and
maybe that's why i didn't have much
interest in
this because it's not like you have to
report something but
the things which really work are
quite different i did manage to get
something for
yandex translate we did get some
improvements but it was
nothing of the kind uh the research
usually does
yeah and maybe the other reason is that
i don't really feel comfortable
yet in machine learning because it's
very
it's very practical it's very
experimental because i come from
mathematical background and
there you can feel things you can be
sure you proved something and
now no one is going to doubt that you
got this
but here it's is it gonna work is it not
gonna work
it sounds reasonable but it's snarky
it's not working
it sounds it doesn't sound reasonable
but it's working for some reason
and um yeah it's really different from
the feelings i am used to so
i used to certainty to something which
makes me calm so analysis makes me calm
because
i get to at least a little bit to
understand what's going on
that's the main reason but it's not what
i was supposed to do i was supposed to
do
context aware machine translation and it
was very reasonable
it was a really good plan and it was
something which is
both useful for production because
currently they're translating
sentences individually and in context
the way mta was trying to use
like um larger segments to translate the
current sentence
because there's they can be some kind of
ambiguity
so to translate one sentence you may
need like a wider context
and it was a really good research topic
and i did
i do have several papers in context of
amt but
like uh arranged marriage shirts
contextual empties
is nice and i could do that yes but
i always have a feeling that it was
something that was chosen for me and
not really it wasn't it wasn't really my
choice and
maybe there is something out there which
i like more and
there is so yeah yeah i find this
fascinating and not only do you
investigate methods to evaluate
you have this these papers on evaluating
like representations in transformers and
so on or evaluating contributions of
source and target to nmt but you even
so there is these this notion of probes
and this is a paper that i find
interesting of these
probes to evaluate embeddings
and also there you don't go
and say i'm going to make a like a a new
one or so on
but you first say why the current ones
don't work
and then you go about make a better one
in this paper
information theoretic probing with mdl
you explain
really well why these why the these
probing methods of these nmt
models or of these nlp models don't work
would you
care to briefly explain what a probe is
and why the classic ones are not really
uh good yeah of course and i can also
explain
why am i really careful in explaining
why they don't work
because i really did have to do that
when you're trying to analyze models in
an opinion generally
you can have different ways to do that
and
you can have different kinds of
questions to ask
because in computer vision is simple
because
you have an image of a cat you have a
classifier it says or
okay there's a cat and you have an
attribution method which shows you
some parts of an image which contributed
and this is your explanation
but in nlp it's not such kind of methods
do not work very well and in nlp there's
whole like different kinds of things you
can ask
i'll come to probe and wait let me just
give you like a general
picture of how i see analysis in nlp
where when analyzing an nlp model you
can be interested for example
in how your inductive biases work or how
different model components work
because when you create some kind of
inductive virus you have
an intuition but what is supposed to
happen right
so you can look at the tension which is
quite popular now you can look at
different attention heads
you can look at neurons and this can
tell you something about how your model
works
also you can look at model predictions
is
kind of standard thing to do is to look
at subject verb agreement and
lots of lots of papers doing that
basically you have a language model and
you
like look at predictions and you
evaluate how good it is
some specific phenomena of language so
if you care about language you can do
that
and probing it's really uh fun stuff
because here you don't care about
predictions you don't care about what
your model generate is generating
you don't care about your model
architecture
and wonder components you just care
about the presentations when you're
feeding
data to a network it can have some
layers and each of them
you have have some kind of a vector
representation of this data
and you can be interested in which kind
of things these
are vectors encode right so
you have a sequence of tokens on the
input
you have several layers you have some
kind of output
and you in probing you're interested
which kinds of things
these vectors encode for example do they
encode part of speech
tags do they encode dependencies do they
encode i don't know
reference such kind of stuff and what
you do is
you take some labeled data for example
you have some data set
where you already know part of speech
tags you feed this data to a network you
get representations
and you train a classifier problem
classifier or probe
to predict this uh part of speech tags
from representations
and usually you say that um okay if the
accuracy is high
probably these representations and code
the thing i want them
to encode if the accuracy is not so high
probably they don't uncover these things
and uh for me the first paper with
probing i saw it was
a 2017 acl paper what do
nmt models and learn about morphology
something like that by jonathan
billingko
and carlos and i was so excited about it
that was like
the first analysis paper i've ever read
and for me it was like
yay great actually
we can ask these kinds of questions
we can actually be interested what's
going on inside the network other than
just
getting higher blue score because
yeah i was at the adex i was at machine
translation team they were
all interested in high blue score and so
yeah
this kind of things was cool but then
what happened is then that
most of analysis started to do this kind
of probing
stuff uh they appealed this models like
elmer
bert and all this all these guys and
there were a lot of papers just
measuring different kinds of stuff and
making some kind of conclusions like
okay elmer
layer one and chords part of speech tags
with accuracy like
96.3 and bird's
layer number six and codes versus
accuracy like
96.4 birth and codes part of speech
labels
better and it's not really it's the
whole other question
why do we trust probing what kind of
conclusions
can we make out of them do we expect
these models to be better just because
they encode little phenomena let's
i don't think we're gonna answer that
kinds of questions but
maybe we could talk about why probing uh
standard problem doesn't work and what
can we do about it
there does seem to be an obsession with
accuracy and it's such a reductionist
number it's the same thing traders have
used these greek letters
what they've done is they've kind of
featurized market conditions and they've
reduced them down to these single
numbers like alpha
and they're just throwing away so much
information we spoke to sarah hooker
from the google brain team the other
week and
she was making this observation as well
that when you compress models
you can preserve headline metrics like
accuracy
but actually it's on the long tail where
all sorts of
you could argue it's memorization that
all of the underrepresented
classes and information is on the long
tail and you're effectively throwing it
away
it's a really good point so much
information is
only part of the things you want so
in a way in the ideal world if you have
if you had infinite amount of training
data for your probe
you'd get a good estimate of mutual
information so whether this
representations actually contain
information about something
but the fact is not is not it's not what
you want
because for example if we take a
randomly initialized model
and just encode things with a random
natural light model
you're going to get as high very high
accuracy
and very often you cannot even according
to accuracy you cannot distinguish
between trained mode or random
nationalized one
and this is a problem with accuracy
because and with mutual information also
because
even render nationalized models uh they
contain this information
about part of speech text because they
know the whole sentence right
they have this information but the
difference is that uh
usually we want to know if the model
encodes something and it is different
well it contains information about
something and
you can extract it if you put a lot of
effort
to it or it does so by itself
like it already caught the information
and you can just easily take it
and this is uh the difference and
another example of my uh standard probe
don't work it was at mlp last year by
june hewitt and president they developed
these control tasks
basically they just used random labels
so for example instead of part of speech
tags you just assign
each word a random label sampled from
the empirical distribution of tags
it means that you still have if you just
look at the text you
still have the same distribution but uh
for different words and they are
assigned randomly so you basically are
saying that
a cat is a preposition a set is a
noun some such kind of things and if you
train a problem classify on that
just trying to predict not part of
speech tags but with random labels
you can do that very well and you're not
going to see a huge difference in
accuracy so basically
accuracy can say that your
representations encode
some random labels and this is crazy
because they do contain information
about labels but they don't encode this
and this is what we're trying to measure
yeah i think a similar kind of
observation was made by sammy benjio's
team as well the classic paper
understanding deep learning re thinking
generalization or
something like that they also made this
statement that neural networks can fit
random levels quite easily and i think
you are also asserting something very
similar and i also
believe that because naturality space
work also
lays out the formation from a very core
hardcore
information theoretic perspective where
you start to fit things and when you
and then later on in the training when
you start to forget things
and eventually when you start fitting
your neural networks with
random levels and stuff there's nothing
to forget and there's nothing to fit in
the first place so i think
that statement holds perfectly fine so
yeah
one one way of conceptualizing it is
maybe saying that
if i simply input my sentence into one
of these
models and let's say the models they
don't
shrink like a cnn but they actively they
just keep layer by layer
it except if they forget something it
should it's it's probably always
possible to extract whatever information
you want
as you say if you put in a lot of work
it doesn't it's not the same thing as
saying this model pays special attention
to part of speech tags it simply says
look i can reverse engineer my way
to these part of speech tags and and it
says nothing about
whether or not they are important and
your paper
produces or suggests a solution
for this where you exactly hit on this
notion
how hard is it to extract this
information would you care to explain
that a bit
yeah maybe let's start with an example
the problem is
with accuracy you don't know whether
this representations encode something or
you just learned to extract this putting
a lot of effort
and what are how can we
distinguish between these two things and
to understand what is the difference
let me give you an example of a model
where we
cannot possibly deny that it's a model
that encodes something
let's let's recall this uh sentiment new
on paper
so this are open eye sentiment here
right so
open air guys trained a language model
on
amazon reviews so they trained a
language model on
lots of reviews and they found in urine
which was responsible for sentiment so
unsupervised
sentiment neuron and so in this case
we cannot i hope that no one can deny
that a model encodes sentiment
we see this we have this neurons which
is responsible for this concept
and we cannot possibly say that oh no
it's just a problem classifier
extracting this now it's a model that
encodes
sentiment and to distinguish between the
cases where we just
can predict sentiment and the model
which encodes
sentiment for example so what is the
difference between these two kinds of
our representations so if we look at
this
representations which come from
sentiment urine model
first of all it would be enough to train
a very simple classifier to predict
those labels
a very simple it would be enough to
train a linear classifier and we need
only one
only one weight for it and everything
else is
zeros and uh you cannot do that for
a random initialized model for example
and on the other hand
the other way of looking at this is that
uh to predict
sentiment from this sentiment urine
representations
you would need only a few examples right
because it's really easy
using this one urine to predict
sentiment you you'll need 10 examples
and you're done
basically and this is the difference
between
cases when a model encodes something or
you can extract it
doing something so this is an intuition
and this is
this was our our example when we thought
about
uh how to how
to explain this difference how to
measure this difference
and luckily there exists this minimum
description length error framework this
notion
and surprisingly the practical ways of
evaluating this description length
explain it
in more detail there are the practical
ways of
length is basically by looking at the
model complexity
how complex should be your model to
extract this information
or how hard it is to predict labels
using small amounts of data so basically
the intuition like transfers perfectly
to this
these two ways of evaluating description
length
you mix you say it is not only important
how well we can predict
let's say sentiment from a given
representation
but also and you start off by saying
how much work we need to put into it but
that's it's difficult to quantify and
then you go into
let's look at the minimum description
length of our model
how but then that also is like yeah
in practice all our probing classifiers
are just going to be linear classifiers
of the same size but then
the the clever thing i find is to say
aha but i can i can count the number of
examples i need to train that classifier
so if i count the number of examples to
train it
then that gives me like a real number
that tells me how hard is it to get this
stuff out of a representation that's
pretty cool
it doesn't give you a number of examples
it's just
you can look at this amount of effort so
when you have
accuracy you just have this you have the
answer to the question can we extract
this information but
with description banks you can you have
these two parts
so one is this final quality part which
corresponds to
accuracy and basically it's saying the
same thing whether
there is this kind of information in the
presentations and the other one the
amount of effort
so in the cold length you can just say
okay this
part of the code says if this
information is present
this part says how hard it takes to
extract it and all together is
the thing we ideally want to measure
that's that's pretty cool and and with
respect to these
to these probes what people want to do
in these probes is as you say they want
to look and they say
this layer does this and this layer does
this and this layer does this
and this is in general is a very
fascinating topic and i think
there are as many opinions as there are
researchers
in the field it's like everyone i've
read a bunch of these papers and
everyone seems to say
a lot of different things you do have an
interesting paper on
the evolution of representations in the
transformer
and where you also you combine a lot of
the similar topics like mutual
information and so on
as you go through the layers and you
find something very interesting
with respect to masked language modeling
do you what do you find in this paper oh
yeah it was a really fun paper actually
it's also ended up having an information
theory in it
still the main story usually we talked
about probing
there are lots of papers doing probing
just measuring different kinds of stuff
showing regards and
usually that's it making some hypothesis
maybe some reasonable statements but
so far it's not it's not clear what is
the process which defines
this behavior and in evolution is what
we try to do is to say that
uh there is a logical explanation to all
this okay there's a
general process which is going on in
your network and
it it's defined by your training
objective and
everything you're gonna see is gonna
is gonna be in accordance to this
general process
to cut a long story short in a network
maybe let's start this way
so uh well can i in this paper you're
characterizing how the learning
objective
determines the information flow in the
model right yeah and you're looking at
the representations of individual tokens
in the transform and how they evolve in
different layers under the different
objectives and
you introduced this concept of the
information bottleneck
so yeah okay the information bottleneck
it's a
it's a really older it's really old
method
and originally it was aimed to
build a compressed representation of
input
which contains as much as possible
information about output
and it was a goal of information
bottlenecks so the
little two objectives laid out with
mutual information
and the objective is minimizing mutual
information with input while
maximizing mutual information about
output
and in this process depending on the
weights of the objectives here
you can get different trade-offs between
compression and prediction so this
compression prediction trade off how
much you uh forget about input and
how well uh you still can predict output
right you point out that there are
regularities in data and that's one of
the reasons why
it is compressible and you're saying
that in this process of evolution
throughout the layers
you're squeezing irrelevant information
while preserving
relevant information but because you
spoke about this this paper from open ai
with the sentiment
how does the model know if it's an
unsupervised pre-training objective
how did it know that sentiment was
salient and that should be preserved
i think it was preserved because it was
important for language modeling
objective breakers what they trained on
was their
well the amazon reviews so they were
all positive or negative and maybe it
was easier for a model
to decide the sentiment and then just to
generate
everything rests like keeping in mind
this uh
idea of sentiment but do you think there
should be a one-to-one mapping between
something which is quite anthropocentric
for example you know adversarial
examples neural networks learn
features that we don't even recognize or
care about so is it just a happy
coincidence that it's
learned sentiment which is something
that we recognize as a concept
uh yes and no yes because
every time you think that a model is
doing something reasonable
and you're happy about it and you're
you're ready to say something like oh
look the model understands these kinds
of things
it's not it doesn't
right but on the other hand yes if there
are some things
which are important for your objective
it tries to uh put effort to
preserve this information and yes
sometimes it happens to be something
we humans think is important like
sentiment or
syntactic error dependencies or
something like that
so information was like it's a really
old theory and
only recently in 2015 it was shown that
if we look at evolution of the layers
so we have input we have output we have
a sequence of layers
we can think about it as uh going
through this compression prediction
stages so
uh what's going on in the network as you
go from
bottom to top from bottom to top and
from input to output is
uh you forget information about input
and preserve relevant information to
output and
the authors of the information but on a
paper showed that you can think about it
about this layers is going through this
information bottleneck
procedure so in a way your output
defines the kinds of information which a
network forgets about
input so you have input but depending on
the output you're going to forget
different things you're going to
preserve different things right about
this input
but it's a very simple story because
it's
when we're talking about like the whole
network the whole input and the whole
output
when we're dealing with language models
and when we're looking at the individual
tokens
it's a bit more complicated because how
transformers work right so
we have uh individual tokens we have
positions
at each stage the stroke and interact
with the child they exchange information
and each at each step each token has a
new representations
new representation for example i was
born today i saw nothing
i talked to you guys today i'm gonna
have a new representation of me because
we communicated i know something more
about myself about the world
and set myself better in this context
and this kind of stuff
and that's what these tokens do and
when we are looking at these individual
tokens we are not we cannot just
say about this the whole input the whole
output because the whole
input is uh your sentence and you're
predicting something else
and when you are looking at individual
tokens so
your input is current token and its
position and
depending on the output for this uh
particular token
its output can be very different for
example for
uh left or right language model your
output is an x token
so if you're looking just at uh these
adjusted representations at this
position they
start from the current token and end up
predicting the next token but and we
would say okay it's losing information
about
input uh trying to fix information about
output
but it's not everything that's going on
because
here i have for example i am current
token
i have my goal i need to grow up and
become this next token but i also have
these other guys around me and they also
have to grow up and
become this next token however the next
organ for them
and they need er i need their help
to get to help me grow up and become
this next token and
they also these other guys also need my
help to to predict whatever they want to
predict
and this this is when this our story is
different from
the standard bottom line exciting
because inside the second you have the
whole input the whole output and
that's everything but here we have uh
we still have input for example current
torque and we still have output
but we also have to preserve some
information which needed for other
tokens
so we cannot i cannot forget everything
about myself because i i need to keep
this information because other guys need
it
and this is when it gets uh interested
and if we look for example at this
objectives
will the left-right language model is
quite simple we start from the current
token
we get the next token in the end and in
this process
uh we can forget something about the
current token
something is still preserved but if in
the end i need to build a representation
of some other token i need to forget
about myself right it's not only about
myself it's about
what comes next what's what comes after
me but if we're talking about mass
language modelling
it's very different because so how this
mlm model is trained so basically it's
vert chain objective it's the main
part of the birth strain you start from
some kind of token it may be a mask
token most of the time
right it may be a random token or some
part of the time it may be even real
token and
you have to go out there in the world
communicate with others
understand if you're if you're a mask
that you have to understand who you are
if you're random token you you have to
figure out somehow that
okay i'm random i need to somehow to get
to my true self
and if you are a correct talk and you
still have to understand somehow okay
i'm in my place everything is right i
just need to like
keep myself untouched and go straight to
the
the finish line and this is a tricky
part because
on the one hand these tokens have to go
out there and communicate with others
to figure this out right this has to
happen at some point this what they were
trained
but after that they have to fulfill
their goal to predict
token identity in the end and so if you
look at the chain process so in training
almost most of the time your input and
your output are different tokens
so on the input side you have either
mask of some random token
on the output you have something which
has to be there and
if you look at this training setting
it's all it's again it's forgetting
information about input which is
irrelevant and building information
about output
so in training is everything is simple
because it's very similar to
left right language model when you have
one token on the input some other token
on the output
but if you take an already trained model
what you have is that you start with
real tokens
they communicate they build some
contextual representation some
generalized representation
of this context and as you go uh up
to the highest layers you start losing
this contextual information
and building a representation about
token again so it goes
in two stages so first it's
can context context encoding when there
where tokens each token forgets a little
bit about
itself and builds a contextual
representation
like the presentations of the things
which could be in this place
and then it's talking reconstruction
it's where you
forget contextual information and try
to reconstruct this token and that's why
when we are looking at a lot of papers
doing problem tasks
they say something like okay let's try
to predict for example
part of speech of the current token
using the representations from different
layers
for example for different models so what
you're going to see is for example for
machine translation encoder it just goes
up
because your encoding right the decoding
part is out there you
don't see it here when you see a left
right language model it goes like
up and down okay and it is reasonable
because
language model has to build a
presentation of next token it doesn't
care anymore about
part of speech tags of the current one
it cares about the next one and
that's what we show and for most english
modeling there's also this pattern but
for for different reasons as we see
right you also first you build
contextual representation
and then you forget it and in different
papers
doing probing doing different kinds of
probing
and doing other stuff for example even
if you look at the birth score paper
in the appendix they have this graph
showing
how effective is this bird score
depending on the layer they're taking
the presentations from
so a couple of words about bird score so
the idea is to build
an evaluation metric based on semantics
and for this we used representations
coming from bird because
they encode meaning in contrast to blue
score which encodes
uh just engram overlap and in the end
they have this
graph showing when using vertical you
can take representations from different
layers
and they evaluate how effective this
metric is depending on where
uh you're taking these representations
and what they see is again
it goes up and down because no players
are not about context anymore they're
about
reconstructing this token and they
forget this contextual
information and also this um
virtually discovers what's called a
people client and so on and so forth i
could talk about this forever because
basically all these papers are showing
the same part and they are following
basically all the results are following
this
general process until it's all explained
by this old
concept of information bottleneck and i
think it's cool at least
for me it makes sense finally finally
something makes sense
so in one of the figures that you have
included in the blog post where we
see how the mutual information plateaus
for a bit in
deeper in the layers and then it starts
to again increase for
mask language modeling so would you
attribute
words by directionality uh to that
because you also mentioned that
a single token's representation is also
contributed by the other representation
naturally i think it is important that
it has access to all contexts and not
just to
left contacts like with the right
language model but
it's not only about white directionality
it's about a chain objective because for
example
a machine translation encoder it's also
bi-directional because it has access to
all context right at the same time
so this is about this evolution it's
about looking information about
input and accumulated information about
output and
if you want the the purpose so imagine
these tokens born
born blank in this word so they verbs as
a sentence or a text
they are born just being a token
identity with
their position and they are born to
become something in the end
so they already have a goal and what
they do in the sentence what they do in
this text how they interact with each
other
which information they take from each
other is defined by this uh
final objective sometimes i wish we
had fun because it would make made
things much easier
just imagine you you would know what do
you have to do
what to take from people how to
communicate them and basically all your
interactions are defined by this final
goldman
unfortunately differently from language
models we don't have one
so this in turn kind of depends on the
difficulty of the training up
objective to some extent so maybe it
would further allow us to quantify
how difficult is a training objective
really is based on this
based on the kind of hypothesis that you
have made in the paper so yeah
really interesting yeah so it's it's
really it's really good point because
yes roughly speaking your target
objective defines
the kinds of information you lose about
input right
and the more complicated your target
objective
the less things you want to lose maybe
more things
that you have to encode so yeah of
course
maybe it could be used the amount of
information you lose about input maybe
it could be used as a measure of how
complicated your train objective is
yeah yeah definitely and in all of the
training objectives that you have
experimented
clearly mask language modeling is a
winner because of the
two qualities it you know gives us as a
byproduct for example
context encoding and label
reconstruction none of the other
training objectives allow us to do that
at this point
do you think there is a how influential
is the data set in all of this because
you've said
for example in these amazon reviews
there was a clear
neuron maybe this is an extreme example
but a neuron for sentiment and
presumably and
you've said so is because probably these
amazon reviews
they are either good or bad so that's a
very strong
a very strong signal presumably if we
only had good reviews
the model would even even with the best
objective
would never learn to encode sentiment
because it doesn't need to
so how much do you have any ideas of
or how important is the data set or what
do we need to
to do when we collect data sets or it's
a hard question
in generally about our analysis we
controlled for the data set
just to to exclude influenced data sets
obviously the same data
just like the same everything the same
random seeds just
different in objectives but yeah of
course depending on
train set the things which a model finds
useful for the strain objectives are
going to be different
and this i mean this is a whole
different story
of how to create training data set and
it's a huge problem in machine
translation also
and there are a lot of lots of kind of
adversarial examples and even know that
in the sunderland tasks for example the
models rely
on some triggers and not on their not on
semantic things but on some
are easily maybe even on some uh
triggers which are not really relevant
to the task
and i don't think i'm gonna have a very
good answer to
that because yeah it really depends on
the task
maybe there is a a little bit of a
bigger question in that
after your investigations and so on what
is something that you think
most of the community still has
a wrong idea about the language models
or
translation or whatever you're looked
into where what is something where you
where you feel that most of the
community is wrong about
yannick i'm just a phd student imagine
me answering that
i'm not going to have a future in this
field
this is the place for strong opinions
but we clearly have to be honest with
ourselves about
the results we see in the models and how
we interpret them
because it's really important for
example
yeah it's important if if you're talking
about the evolution paper and the main
outcome maybe
we need to understand the general
process
behind this phenomenon rather than
measuring a lot of stuff
because once you understand this general
process you don't need to
measure the stuff and say or the
patterns are different
we don't know why it is but we observe
that they are of course
they are they have to be different it's
supposed to be so it was their destiny
to behave this way there was no other
way
it could be done but yeah i think let's
pose my point from the evolution paper
and i mean builder this description then
clean
yes it's important to understand what's
going on it's important how to measure
it but
it's really a hard question of
[Music]
maybe the main thing we need to work on
is how to interpret the results
we can now we can we have lots of
methods so we can measure different
stuff we have
lots of list test sets for problem
classifiers we have a lot of benchmarks
but
so far i think we don't know uh what to
take out of this results what does it
mean that
this model like gives you 0.3 accuracy
better on some benchmark
and yeah i don't want to go too far down
this path because it goes
on forever but we've been speaking to
some good old-fashioned ai people and
they
have been telling us that natural
language processing is not the same
thing as natural language understanding
and statistical language models as we
can get into a philosophical debate of
what does it mean
to understand that if we ask gpt-3
something like how many feet fit in a
shoe or anything that requires what you
might call reasoning
it it doesn't seem to work so do you
agree that
natural language processing is glorified
statistical text processing or do you
think we can actually make something
that
understands whatever that means no it's
called processing of course it's
processing
so yes of course our i don't think the
model understand
because they don't understand things as
reader
and at the very least you need to
if you work at least a little bit in
this field you'll see
and you'll see what actually your models
are doing you'll see that it's just
some kind of statistical behavior so
there are some statistics in the data
they capture the statistics and
they get it out for you and they're not
going to understand things
as we do and maybe an example
from context of amt it's how i usually
illustrate what's going on in context of
empty and why do we need context
for example imagine you have a sentence
i'm here telling you this
and without context it's not possible to
understand
who is i where is here who is you and
what is this
that i'm telling you and even with
context it wouldn't be possible to
understand
just from the text what's going on you
have to be part of it
and maybe we'll get better so there's a
whole other stuff with grounding
alimony's coming in in play and
so on and so forth and i think at least
when we are
dealing only with text it's not possible
to really understand
things and even if
with this language models being as good
as they are if you play with them you
still
see that it's just just capturing some
statistics it's not
it's not really understanding it's not
it doesn't have this underlying
meaning behind it because when you talk
about context as well i i think by that
you might also mean knowledge or common
knowledge
and this guy was pointing out that
there's lots of missing information in
our communication
and i we have a common knowledge so we
in a way we compress our communication
and then you need to
perform some reasoning to fill in the
missing gaps yeah
yeah but to that end one could argue
that an entire
our models you know lifetimes are
entirely
limited to the training data it's
exposed to but we as human beings we are
exposed to much
all the other things that we get to see
on a day-to-day uh
basis so the sense of common sense would
of course be you know
far more elegant capacity for us because
we are entitled and exposed to
a whole lot of things whereas a model is
only exposed to its lifetime
of interacting with the training dataset
so yeah
there are all kinds of arguments to that
line
it does raise the question though of
what does it mean to understand
and i think where these go fi people
they say that there's lots of lexical
ambiguities and language
but with natural language understanding
you're trying to get to
what was the thought behind the
utterance yeah and
there's no ambiguity there we always
seem to understand what we mean
but i don't know how to verbalize that
because
just as an example we've been talking to
gpt3 quite a lot we've managed to get
access to it
and it's really difficult to ascertain
whether or not
if i was evaluating it if i was doing
some pronoun disambiguation or something
it's really difficult for me to evaluate
whether or not it has actually got the
right answer because it's just given me
a bunch of tokens
and it might contradict itself it's too
smart for you
it was too smart for all of us it's just
tricking us
it's just i'm just a stupid statistical
model
and it's just manipulating you to take
over the the world
but yeah it's yeah it's really and it
also raises the question of i think
what people try to to say is that even
though gpt3 and
these other language models are only
trained on their training data
the emerging thing is something like
understanding but but i think that's
hotly debated and
probably no one has a as if he had a
real answer
it's even hard to define what do what do
we mean by
meaning and let alone just to evaluate
it somehow
in a model exactly so
so you um switching tops a little bit
you do have an nlp course i do
yes yes well it's
nlp course it's called an opi course
it's not full
yet um it's something
i was working on on my isolation this
summer while
i was waiting to get a uk visa because
it's a long story but yeah i was
supposed to i left the index i was
supposed to come to edinburgh
in the spring uh and yeah basically
i had everything planned i had my had my
suitcase packed and
now the current happened and yay i got
stuck in
six months in moscow for no reason
there's no plans to have an apartment
there so
yeah and uh this is when um i
created this nlp course and this is guys
uh
if you're struggling full balls no
communication this is what came out of
me
maybe you can at some point you can
share what came out of you but
this is what i did so it was my attempt
to come up with something
useful when i didn't know uh what was
gonna
be like what what teaching was gonna be
like in
autumn because uh you know i teach an op
course at this yandex school of data
analysis
and uh i was planning to move to
edinburgh spring then came back to
moscow to teach and then come back and
this uh all this currently and i wasn't
even sure that
we were going to have the course or
teaching or all the stuff
and yeah
this what what got me thinking about it
and
there were other questions about
teaching per se i um
i thought about a lot uh in previous
years because
i had a feeling that um the standard
format is not suitable
for everyone it doesn't have this
individual approach i would love to have
for my students
because you have a lecture yes you're
you have to tell something people right
and on the one hand um some people
came there just to part the course it's
reality because
i don't think nlp is the best thing
everyone should be interested in we have
our own interest right
and so for some people it may be too
much for other people
it may be it too later some people
just want to know what's it about other
people just
they really want to do research
afterwards and they
are ready to put effort to read papers
to
all these kinds of stuff so it's about
the lecture part
and the other question is okay
we have a lecture and what is the best
way for students to
just you know recap some material it's
not feasible
just to like click through the video or
like
look at the slides because it's not it's
not user friendly you know
and the other thing again it's about
um usually you know yes you can have
like a lecture you
can give some links okay read also list
papers
right and a bunch of papers and when
you're starting it's
uh it's nearly impossible to read all of
them to understand
perfectly uh to get the idea to
understand how the field is going on
uh because uh well papers
by themselves they are not usually user
friendly and
like we talked about this meaning common
sense and
all the stuff it's uh when you're coming
into the field
uh when you're trying to read the
research paper you
understand it perfectly you still need
to have some kind of
understanding of this like common
knowledge of the field right
uh at least to get this understand okay
these parts they write because just they
have to like related work introduction
right
and this is the main idea and this is
why it's cool and
uh it's hard um when i started i think
it's hard to
get this main idea quickly it's
impossible for a young student to just
skim through the paper get them an idea
and move on and to get
this feeling of the field
and yeah and this is like
my anal pickers was uh my version of
um how i see
be done because uh so
it first of all it's a suitable format
for students to recap some material to
look up to the things because it's like
a lecture in the blog post with lots of
visualizations
and they can play these things for
example if they're
embeddings they'll have this disney
projection you can like basically you
can work through this
embedding space and to look what's going
on uh
and yeah so i put like really a lot of
effort to the lectures to make them
interactive to make them you know there
are a lot of stuff where you
have to where i'm saying just like okay
or just go through the slides and um
each student like by himself by
themselves can
just go through the slides and uh at
their own pace
you know because at lecture again it's
gonna be too slow for someone it's gonna
be too quickly for
other other people it's it's never gonna
be good for anyone
uh never and but in this format they
have an opportunity to just
um do it as they like do it at their own
pace
just to uh take all the time they need
to look at the figures just to like uh
look at the interactive stuff and their
own um
speed right and this is about
lectures and um the other stuff i have
is um
related related papers but it's not just
links with papers it's
uh little summaries it's also
illustrations with all the stuff and
what i try to do is to give
the students an opportunity to quickly
get a general idea what other things are
going on in this field for example
there's a lecture basically like
vertebrating
the standard stuff yes there's a
statistical ones count count based
neural based and all the stuff but after
that
okay there can be for example gender
barriers
let's see how this can be mitigated we
can look at semantic shift we can look
at multilingual things
we can look at a theological explanation
of what's going on
we can look at different ways to
evaluate them and so on and
so you have a lot of papers and it's
just enough to like
a short like two sentence to three
sentence summary
and uh it will take you about like 10
minutes to go over all the papers and
just to get an idea of what are other
things which are going on
and you don't need to spend a week
reading all these papers you just
need 10 minutes to go over that and if
there is something you like you can
click to expand
this scene and just to read the full
version
of the things you care about and after
that once you get
this main idea once you understand it
given only the context of the lecture
which is nearly impossible if you read
the paper right away
after that if you're interested enough
you can look you can read the
original papers i'm not against that
don't get me wrong
but once you get this main idea you are
like
ready you're equipped enough to go read
the paper
and to when keeping this main idea in
mind you are ready to
to frame all the things you read and
this general understanding behind it
and well but related papers it's not my
favorite part
and it's not the favorite part by
feedback
by the way i was at mlp last week and i
got
surprisingly i got a lot of our students
from different countries
contacting me and saying lena have you
taken your course that's great to
do it more and yeah so it was really
great and they
but they said they liked more than uh
research thinking exercises and this is
the part of my favorite part as well
i was yeah so my personal favorite part
from your courses
you encourage students to ask research
questions formulate research questions
which is uber cool to me i am a big mooc
fan by the way
and i got to know about your quotes from
sebastian ruder's newsletter just as a
fun fact for our viewers
so immediately i jumped straight to it
and when i discovered that section on
you know research questions
and stuff like that so i found it to be
uber cool and yeah
it's one of my personal favorites of
your course as well yeah so what are
these exercises are
when i to tandex yeah it may sound crazy
but i was
a like grown-up research scientist with
grown-up responsibilities and
when i left i was a senior research
scientist and one of the
things i had to do was supervise interns
and students and we did have some papers
with my interns and students there
but yeah and the main when you're
working with students in this way
that it's really hard even if it's a
super cool student if
they like learned all the lecture stuff
there's still this point when you
uh there's a difference between when
you're given information
and when you have to like do something
yourself
and to do something novel right like
even think
about ways to extend what you learned
so you can for example someone comes to
you and tells you
here are words embeddings they work like
leaks
these are their properties and do
something with it it's
like what what am i supposed to do how
am i supposed to extend this what could
be possible ideas and this is a really
scary point for people because
yeah that feeling that you have no idea
what to do that you have no idea how to
do it and
even when you start reading papers it's
you read the paper and
you don't see straight away well if you
see you're super cool you're gonna
you're gonna do great in this field but
usually what happens
is that when you read a paper oh
god this is so cool some cool guys
did some great stuff how did they come
to this
how am i supposed to come to this and
it's a really
that point when you can get scared and
you this is the point you can get aware
and
yeah so here my purpose was to
give that feeling that it's not just an
information it's not just
something static you are given and
that's it
you it's just enough to be reasonable
to try reasonable things and they work
if they're not working you just try
another reasonable things
at some point it's going to be okay so
and what is the research thinking
exercise
so you have a lecture and then
based on something you already know i
can ask some things for example
we saw this and this stuff thinks this
is good or
what kind of problems can be there right
imagine
there's some kind of example what do you
think about it and
uh a student has to think
at least for for a minute and they can
click on there on the button to expand
the answer what i think about it on
what other papers thought about it and
in this way
oh aft after that i can ask okay when we
understand the problem
uh how can you think this for example
our
based on this idea and so you have some
kind of guidance you have
uh in a way someone asking you questions
and my idea was to like replace since i
didn't know if i was going to teach
this course in person my idea was to do
everything possible to replace myself
and
put something out there instead of me
and this was like me
asking questions guiding students
through some
some path of thinking i don't know yeah
and studies show
that when you are when you put an effort
to get some kind of information uh you
are more likely to
learn it other than and not when you're
just given some kind of information and
you even if you're just like uh
read this question you think about it
for a minute and you look at the answer
it's gonna be like it's very different
if i just tell you this
it's very different and if you're a
really good student which
if you're a student if you're listening
to this please do it this way just
read the question and play that out for
a day or two or maybe a week
even if you are not thinking about it
all the time it's just
something is going on in your brain
you'll notice something is going on
and when you come down well if you think
about it you're creating some kind of a
framework
in your brain where you have concepts
and
you can hang things off those i feel
sometimes when i prepare for street talk
episodes
i have to understand something in order
to explain it
and when i do understand it even if i
forget it i'll very quickly
get it back again if i need to because i
understood it at some point
in the past and because of a need that
understanding part
rose from a need because you had to
prepare it for
the ml street talk episode and need give
birth
birth to this kind of effectivity to
some extent it's not just someone told
you about this right you like
you put your effort to do that and
that's that's that's what counts and if
you're willing to
spend at least some kind of time to do
that
first of all you'll see that most of the
time it's enough like
just based on one lecture of the common
stuff
uh you see that even reasonable
when you've just been reasonable it's
usually
like it's already quite a lot and you'll
see that
okay um maybe i'll do it this way and
you click and you see okay this paper
let's level the paper
which did exactly the same and it's not
uh and in the first lecture also have
examples for example based on
uh 1995 paper for account-based
embeddings how to
make them better and like modern ones
and
you'll see that the process of thinking
the research process is the same so you
have
uh some understanding of what's going on
right now of the current state of things
you are just starting being reasonable
and you already get some results
okay of course in the end er you can
like end up very far from what you
started and
in the end you you can get a paper which
looks like really cool and
you didn't even realize how this
happened at least for me it's like
how this happened to me okay but yeah
and
it's i wanted to just help to people to
get this feeling that
it's okay it's not that hard it's okay
that
you just read the paper you don't
understand how to get this this is how
you can
get to know how to
[Music]
get to learn about this process at least
to not just
take the knowledge but to put your
effort to
expand it and i think it's it's gonna be
useful i hope it's gonna be useful yeah
it's not finished yet
it's going to be more papers more
exercises yeah i was going to ask you
what tools do you use
do you use cloud providers did are you a
matlab hacker are you a python person
what sketch out your tool stack and
what what is a day in the life of leno
hacking doing all of this stuff
day in life after i already knew what
your html in case i says or before
because when it when it started it was
like okay i have this
huge idea i don't know how to do
what is html how to do all this cool
stuff to make it look good
so about one month in june i spent just
to
try and to understand how russia made
works how ksis works because i had
personal page but it was like from some
template
i just asserted my name and like but you
know this this kind of stuff but the
course
was different things that was like to
design
the whole and the whole it would look
like and for me it's
it's important because it has to give me
that feeling i have inside
and if it doesn't if it's not right yeah
so
coming back to the course it's html
curses
a little bit of javascript but for
simple things just like
pushing the button and do something for
pictures
it's uh you'd be surprised it's a
powerpoint
it's powerpoint print screen and
paint painted to give
something like this it's amazing what
you can do in powerpoint
for your experiment when you write your
papers and so on yeah for experiment
it's python it's python it's python it's
uh tensorflow not because i'm a mother
cased
because but because we had to use it at
yandex because
uh yeah at the index i used yandex
internal framework and
it's on tensorflow so i use tensorflow
i'm not very happy about it but
now it's a strange situation because i'm
not happy with tender flow
i don't have much experience with pie
church so
i'm stuck on this one and to be honest i
don't really like
coding it's my bottom line is my bottom
neck
i like writing papers i like thinking i
like drawing fancy pictures but
i don't like coding
so you're more of a more of a scientist
than an engineer
yeah yeah my background was in
mathematics and this was because
i didn't have to do anything and my main
what i liked about mathematics was
at least what i started how it worked
you don't have to know anything you can
just derive everything you want
with history with all the stuff even
with physics you have to learn
things you have to learn formulas you
have to learn facts it was a mathematics
you don't have to do anything
maybe i'm just lazy i don't know you
have to know
nothing you can't just derive all the
stuff you and it's so
beautiful you come to the first lecture
you have definition of
of real numbers right you have this 24x
arms
and that's it and let's eat you don't
need anything
after that you can just get it out of it
and
yeah we'll quote you on that you know
that there
we will go we'll just put this clip
we'll just put this clip live
in mathematics you don't need to know
anything you don't need to do anything
by elena just this clip
it's gonna be i think it's the do bit
you don't need to do anything
but that was the way it was for me and
yeah now when i
like have to learn experiments because
without an experiment
i don't know if it works or not you
don't need to do that in mathematics you
just
prove things you're sure everyone is
sure
everyone is happy you are done you're
you're good tears
because python is the complete diametric
opposite of that because at least with
um
some statically typed languages you have
some idea when you compile it whether it
will work or not whereas with python
you're
stabbing in the dark aren't you
yeah true at some point i used to see
plus
but it was a funny story i when i
when i interviewed a free andex for this
position at production
for the first time they warned me
they're going to be coding interviews
and i was a mathematician before i never
had
any kind of coding i had some kind of
code and at the university but it was
like
done and forgotten and for interviews i
actually read the first several chapters
of strauss troop
just to understand okay this is how
simple works okay
obviously algorithmic side it's it's
good because it's like
basically solving mathematic
mathematical tasks to understand the
complexity and that's it and it's the
final thing that
they interviewed so they have like like
c plus
accordion interview algorithm interview
statistics probability theory machine
learning for this
first partition and apparently back then
when at some point i needed something
from production teams and
that was there was the guy who
interviewed me
we were like oh guys we are data
scientists we need you to code this and
that
they're like you have lena she's so good
at class you just
have to give it to her why but why are
you coming to us
like in the state where i i never saw
like a real simplest code in my life
before that
yeah that's the problem with interviews
and listening code on the desk it's my
meditation i can do that i can do like
like
actually open some framework i if you
give me a computer and ask
just open something and say plus and
write i won't be able to do that
amazing lena voiter it's been an
absolute honor and thank you so much for
joining us today
thank you it's been fun thank you
amazing anyway i really hope you've
enjoyed the episode today as always
we've had so much fun making it
remember to like comment and subscribe
we love reading your comments and we'll
see you back
next week